these Germans built the wall to prevent
people from escaping but many people
still tried here in the museum you can
see the car the kind of car people tried
to escape in hiding under the hood
hiding in the back hiding under the main
part of the car people tried to go out
and hot air balloons people some people
even built submarines to try to go under
the river or the canals in Berlin all
sorts of ways people try to escape some
were successful but many were not almost
200 people were killed actually at the
wall in Berlin trying to escape many
more were killed on the border between
the two parts of Germany now after
germany united in 1990 some of the
former top east german political and
military leaders were put on trial and
charged with manslaughter charged for
the murder of these people who were
killed crossing the border so the issue
of responsibility of who is really to
blame for this wall is in fact a very
important one and what I'm going to talk
to you about today I'm going to first
show you a remind you of the geography
here of the map of Berlin and Germany
Germany and its capital city were
divided into four zones in the West the
US Great Britain and France had zones of
Germany that became West Germany and
they had zones of Berlin that became
West Berlin the Soviet zone became East
Germany and the Soviets owner Berlin of
course became East Berlin in 1952 the
border between East and West Germany was
effectively closed for free movement
which meant that after 1952 now the two
German states were created in 1949 in
1952 the border between them was closed
which meant that only Berlin was open
after 1952
and the East German leader was not happy
with that as you'll learn in the next
transparency it'll show you the layers
of the border it wasn't just a wall and
in many cases it wasn't just one wall
there were almost always two walls and
sometimes even three walls as well as
trenches and ditches and places for
guard dogs to run guard towers it was a
living threatening border regime meant
to prevent anyone from escaping and the
wall itself as you'll see here which
went up in 1961 encircled West Berlin it
was about a hundred and two miles long
about 35 of those miles were through the
center of Berlin in the center of that
picture there the average height was
almost 12 feet it broke off 192 streets
32 train lines 8 metro lines 3 highways
and various rivers and lakes before
August 13 1961 there were many there
were in fact about 81 crossing points on
the border between West Berlin and the
surrounding parts of East Berlin and
East Germany these crossing points were
reduced immediately to 11 and then
ultimately 6 so that as you can imagine
took a lot of men and a lot of wall and
a lot of barbed wire and cement to
really make that a tight border so this
was a very serious thing that affected
the lives of many people now why did I
decide to write this book which is
called driving the Soviets up the wall
so
at East German relations from nineteen
fifty three to nineteen sixty one it
covers the period from Stalin's death in
1953 through the building of the wall in
1961 well there were two reasons I wrote
this book the first was growing up
during the Cold War as of course Peter
knows far better than I he was very
involved wondering what was going on on
the other side on the Communist side
growing up in the US it was such a
mystery how did they think how did the
Soviet leaders in the Kremlin think how
did they make their decisions this was a
source of great curiosity to me and the
second sort of mystery to me was how
could a city and a country be divided
but particularly a city I mean imagine I
always like to tell my students you know
imagine a wall in Washington and it
happened to cut right through the campus
of George Washington University you know
you couldn't see your friends you
couldn't go to your favorite classes but
just imagine for a second a wall going
through your own Street and the
neighbors used to go have lunch with
every Saturday suddenly you couldn't get
there to say nothing of your grandmother
who you would visit every weekend and
you suddenly couldn't get to her for a
few years until finally they let you pay
money and apply for a visa and go see
her for one day so I wanted to
understand this this crazy sort of
inhuman thing the Berlin Wall and the
communist decision-making behind it what
I also try to do in the book and what I
want to do today for you is to give you
a picture of the two personalities of
the leaders that we're talking about the
leader of the Soviet Union Nikita
Khrushchev who succeeded Joseph Stalin
and the leader of East Germany valter
Ulbricht there were basically only two
leaders of East Germany Ulbricht led
from the beginning from 49 through 71
and then Erich Honecker took over from
71 to 80 9 and almost till the fall of
the wall so I want to give you a sense
of
who they were how they thought what
their involvement was in this decision
this historic decision of the Cold War
to build the Berlin Wall and finally
what I want to do is give you sort of a
framework for understanding the
historical details and the personalities
and the framework is that of an alliance
relationship we're used to thinking of
the u.s. having alliances and allies and
thinking about the politics that go on
for example between the u.s. and France
or you know the US and West Germany but
I want to talk about an alliance on the
Soviet side the Soviet East German
alliance and in fact talk about some of
the surprising ways in which a clearly
much weaker power namely East Germany
could in fact exert important influence
over a superpower the Soviet superpower
the Kremlin so that's what I'm going to
talk to you about today now initially
when I was starting my research on this
in 1987 1988 1989 I was rather bored
because for historian you need primary
sources you mean documents you want to
read the good stuff but of course we
couldn't get access to any of that
because the Cold War was on and there
was no way that a scholar from the
United States was gonna waltz into the
archives and Moscow worries Berlin and
get anything interesting so I was
reading everything that had been written
but was rather bored doing it when I got
on a plane and went to West Berlin as
you heard from Peter and the wall came
down now I remember celebrating with
everyone on the streets of Berlin and
they had champagne everywhere and every
people were hugging and kissing I saw
many of the borders opening East Germans
driving through West Germans showering
them with flowers with West room and
money with champagne was very moving
everyone was so happy and I thought no
one is going to want to read the sad
depressing story of why the wall was
built when they can
now read all these wonderful happy
stories about the wall coming down you
know what am I gonna do maybe I should
rethink this but then I thought you know
maybe the very fact of the wall coming
down is going to mean that the archives
are going to be open and I'm in fact
going to get to tell the story no one
was able to tell before about how did
the Soviets in East Germans come to the
decision to build the Berlin Wall and
luckily that is what happened so over
the course of the next seven years I
used five different archives in Moscow
in berlin in Moscow I use the archives
of the foreign ministry and the Central
Committee of the party the top
decision-making body under the Politburo
and in Berlin I use three archives the
archives of the former ruling party
socialist unity party the foreign
ministry archives as well as something
beloved to the spy museum the Stasi
archives those archives of the East
German secret police so I was able to
use five archives as well as interview
many former Soviet nice German diplomats
to ask them in fact to talk about the
story of the decision to build the
Berlin Wall I was very lucky to be one
of the first scholars into these
archives particularly in Moscow because
in the early Yeltsin period when there
was a really flowering of us Russian
relations the archival doors were quite
open and so I was able to get some
fantastic things that include letters
back and forth between the Soviet and
East German leaders word for word
memorandum conversations all sorts of
high-level fantastic documents that only
two years later were mostly closed down
as Russia became more nationalistic and
thus so did its archival policy and
nobody really was able to get these
documents not even if you were from
Russia but certainly not if you were
from the West so I was there for what we
call the Golden Age of archival access
in Moscow in 1992 in 1993 and i have
included large excerpts of documents in
my book and i'm going to in fact show
you some of those documents today well
there are two bookends framing my book
the first is the beginning in march of
1953 when the soviets refused an East
German request to closed the border in
Berlin and then of course it ends in
1961 where the Soviets changed their
mind and agreed and so the book tells
the story of how was it that the Soviets
change their mind and that the how did
the East Germans play such an important
role in getting the Soviets to change
their mind in ways that you wouldn't
have expected now the general situation
in East Germany and East Berlin in the
1950s that gave rise to the desire of
the leader to close the border in Berlin
was of course the refugee exodus between
1953 and 1961 over ten percent of the
East German population left the country
to go west for better working
opportunities more money more freedom
all these kinds of things and in fact it
was fifteen percent of the working
population of East Germany so this was a
real problem something also a key part
of this museum Berlin was spy central in
the cold war and of course this wasn't
just East Berlin but it was also West
Berlin both sides had many agents and
were of course using all the advantages
of this open city with two systems to
run agents and try to find out what was
happening on the other side
and the East Germans of course didn't
like this at all and neither did the
Soviets that here was this island of
Western democracy and capitalism West
Berlin was this island surrounded by the
Soviet bloc yet they had all these
listening posts to you know pick up on
the conversations in the Warsaw Pact and
these Germans the Soviets didn't like
this at all so this was yet another
reason that we're trying to do something
sort of closed down West Berlin so the
first document that I want to share with
you is what what we historians would
really call a smoking gun you know you
you work hours and hours weeks months in
the archives you look through all sorts
of boring documents and sometimes you
come up with a great document and this
was one of them this is the Soviet
refusal in march of 1953 to these
germans i've underlined the key things
and i'm going to read it and talk about
it the soviet refusal saying no you
can't close the border in berlin at the
bottom of the first paragraph i've put
it in caps and underlined it they said
this is unacceptable and grossly
simplistic not we expect the Kremlin was
saying but that's what they said then in
the next paragraph in part a they
essentially say you must be kidding
Berlin is a huge City you can't divide a
huge city like this if they say it would
violate the established order of city
life it would disorganize the economy it
would negatively affect the interests of
the population and it would call forth
bitterness and dissatisfaction from the
Berliners against you East Germans and
against us the Soviets and then in the
bottom paragraph in C they say doing
this would complicate Soviet relations
with the US Great Britain and France
something we can and must avoid so you
know this isn't just sort of no we don't
think so
this is no for the following four or
five reasons that are very clearly laid
out which make perfect sense you know
anyone thinking rationally would have
said this and the Soviets said this for
many years the East German leader Walter
Ulbricht however just didn't like this
answer and kept persistently nagging and
sort of manipulating the Soviets to
change their mind now as I've made clear
a key part of this story is this our
alliance relationship between the strong
power the Soviets and the weaker power
these Germans and so one of the broader
points I make in this book isn't about
the importance of allies the importance
of smaller powers during the Cold War
many people think you know the Cold War
if you just study what Washington and
Moscow did that's enough the US and the
Soviets they were the superpowers they
called all the shots that's it well yes
they were you obviously can't understand
it without understanding us and Russian
policy but it's insufficient it turns
out that there were other countries that
were also essential to just some of the
general dynamics of the Cold War as well
as some of the specific events so to
really understand what went on you've
got to study both the superpowers and
some of their key allies now allies
mattered in two key ways during the Cold
War the first way is because the
superpowers believed they did it's the
domino theory um it's it's feeling that
in this cold war struggle your
reputation is riding on having more
allies than the other side and if you
look like you're the one that people are
coming to your side of the fight and
they're leaving the other side you look
good you don't want to be the one that
everybody's deserting and they're
looking toward Moscow for example so for
both the US and the Soviet Union and
documents from the archives attest to
this on both
odds there were key moments when they
really felt our reputation as a super
power and as a representative of either
democracy or communism our reputation is
riding on the success of our allies we
will look bad if they don't do well and
nowhere was this more clear than the
center of the Cold War in the two parts
of Germany in the two parts of Berlin
and I'm going to give you some examples
later but this crucial sense that your
reputation is riding on how your German
allied does the second reason that
allies were important during the Cold
War is that they sometimes acted
independently of their superpower patron
again this isn't something you thought
of and certainly we didn't mostly think
of it during the Cold War as Peter
mentioned it was a sense that these were
puppets there were satellites Moscow
calls all the shots but there's there's
just no way you can read the documents
in the communist archives and hold to
that conclusion you just can't it's
absolutely clear that there were moments
when East Germany as well as Cuba as
well as North Vietnam as well as North
Korea were definitely acting
independently of Moscow and in ways that
mattered for the Cold War now with
regard to these German part of this as I
write in the book I'm talking about the
leader of East Germany Walter Ulbricht
all breaks tenacity in pursuing his goal
of closing the refugees escape hatch to
West Berlin was like the recurring
drumbeat in the baseline of the
Beethoven Violin Concerto ominous
building in intensity and not always
under the conductor's control the book
is basically three case studies of
relations between the superpower Soviet
Union and East Germany and in each of
the three cases between 1953 and 1961
you see the East German leaders either
hindering stated Soviet policies from
being successfully carried out or
actively
pushing the Soviets to change their
policies the first case is 1953 when the
Soviets insisted the East Germans
moderate their policies feeling that
they had too harsh of a Stalinist policy
and it was leading everybody to escape
and the East German leader totally
resisted the second case was in nineteen
56 and 57 crew shas fav famous secret
speech denouncing Stalin an incredibly
courageous thing perhaps the most
courageous act anybody did during the
Cold War and as part of his denunciation
of Stalin he also called on all of his
allies to D Stalin eyes their domestic
and foreign policies and again ulbricht
resisted and finally the crisis over
Berlin between nineteen fifty eight and
nineteen sixty one where Khrushchev was
trying to get an agreement with the west
on Berlin as i'll talk about in detail
Ulbricht very much tried to act
unilaterally and undercut what
Khrushchev was trying to do so this is
all not what you would expect if you
adopted the traditional Cold War view
that Moscow called the shots in East
Germany was just a satellite with no
room for autonomy now as I mentioned the
key point I want you all to to take away
is that these smaller powers such as
East Germany played an essential role
and part of that was because of the
commitment of Nikita Khrushchev to doing
whatever he could to make sure his East
German Ally looked really good and the
frontline aspect of Berlin is what made
this competition between communism and
capitalism between communism and
democracy so essential so in the second
clip I'm going to show you you're going
to get a very vivid sense of exactly
what it meant that Berlin
at the front line of the Cold War this
shows a street in the center of Berlin
where the houses the front of the house
was in West Burt was in East Berlin and
the back of the house was in West Berlin
so you could walk in one door and go out
the other and go to freedom until they
boarded up the windows
you
helping people escape became a routine
assignment for West Berlin's fire
brigade anahi hazardous puters is true i
am dutch later spring waitin until it
became the custom but people who wanted
to escape people who wanted to leave
would throw little pieces of paper out
of the windows into Bernard straße Asha
Dino mark your number of the building
the floor the window second or third
window was written on it and the time
for example tennis park see that they
wanted to join you no one seeing her
arms were much spring here are perhaps
the most dramatic scenes ever to come
out of Berlin tossing belongings from
the window of an apartment overlooking
the western border and freedom an
escapee is prepared to jump to safety
into a net held by police environment of
West Berlin
and here is a rescue episode that is
even more extraordinary an attempt is
being made by sympathetic Germans to
assure the escape of a brave woman while
communist police tried to pull er back
through the window below there is
freedom grip of blood chilling sequence
that the news of the day camera follows
to its dramatic conclusion
that lad the East Germans blocked even
this last loophole thank you so makes it
very clear this was the front line and
it was perfectly obvious you know your
reputation was riding on what was going
on the West felt good about this all
this kind of footage and of course that
the background this is clearly Western
you know freedom's grip below you can
imagine this was not shown on communist
TV these kinds of things but some some
in the communist bloc were more willing
to recognize the problem than others the
Ambassador to East Berlin from Moscow
Mikhail / Vulcan was all too aware of
the problem he wrote back to Moscow in
1959 he said the presence in Berlin of
an open and to speak to the point
uncontrolled border between the
socialist and capitalist worlds
unwittingly prompts the population to
make a comparison between both parts of
the city which unfortunately does not
always turn out in favor of democratic
or East Berlin so um he was all too
aware given that he was posted he was
the ambassador there you know he
couldn't be hiding his head in the sand
he knew what was going on um krrish off
however the Soviet leader was so
optimistic about communism and the
communism was going to win and it was
the superior system that it took him
until really the last minute to fully
understand that it wasn't going to make
it on its own in East Berlin now he I
mean he recognized the problem in 1956
Khrushchev said the conflict between
socialism and capitalism proceeds in
East Germany as a country with open
borders as a result particular attention
by all forces in the socialist bloc must
be directed toward East German Vic
in the competition so he's essentially
saying East Germany's at the frontline
everybody's watching we have to make
sure it wins in the competition Mao
Zedong the leader of communist China
said the same thing he said a victory in
this question is a victory of the entire
piece camp the socialist camp and a
failure would be a failure of the entire
socialist camp so you've got both crews
chef and mouse saying essentially the
reputation of communism is riding on
what happens at the front line in East
Berlin and East Germany another sort of
smoking gun document that gives the best
flavor of how very important to
Khrushchev success in East Germany was
this is a document from crew shots
closest advisor and Presidium colleague
Ann estas Mikoyan Mikoyan went to East
Berlin in June of 1961 and he really
gave voice to the central way of
understanding how it was that
essentially East Germany could persuade
the reluctant Soviets the reluctant crew
shop into changing his mind and closing
the border in this quote which is
certainly what crucia felt it makes it
very clear he says East Germany is the
westernmost outpost of the socialist
camp therefore many people look at East
Germany our Marxist Leninist theory must
prove itself in the GDR the German
Democratic Republic East Germany it goes
goes on to say Marxism was born in
Germany it must prove its correctness
and value here we must do everything so
that your development constantly in
steadily goes forward you cannot do this
alone the Soviet Union must and will
help with this we cannot and must not
lose out to West Germany and then in the
final paragraph here sort of the key
thing he says if socialism does not win
in East Germany
if communism does not prove itself is
superior and vital here then we the
Soviets have not won the issue is this
fundamental to us therefore we cannot
proceed in such a way with any other
country and this is also the reason that
East Germany occupies first place in
negotiations or credits so it's
absolutely clear reputation of communism
is riding on in cruise shots views
riding on the success of East Germany
and the next clip I want to show you the
final clip from the CNN really is a
fantastic demonstration of Khrushchev's
optimism that communism is the way of
the future
he tried to impress Khrushchev with
America's advances in color television
there are some instances where you may
be ahead of us for example in the
development of your of the thrust of
your rockets for the investigation of
outer space there may be some instances
for example color television where we're
ahead of you but in order for both of us
for both of my an event you both of us
we thought of it we were never close to
eat anything even a giftie give us if
you need you what did you see the
picture huh Nixon was no competition for
chairman Khrushchev he generally ran the
show whenever he was around and his
incredible sort of boisterous and you
know infectious enthusiasm about
communism is vividly clear here now
you've all heard of the domino theory if
one country goes the others will go with
it others in the area such as in Vietnam
Southeast Asia well you could call
Berlin and Germany in fact super dominos
not just dominoes in the Cold War but
super dominoes or super allies to the US
and the Soviet Union each feeling that
the way it's part of Berlin and it's
part of Germany fared in the Cold War
was essential to its own reputation both
presidents Eisenhower and Kennedy felt
this way about West Germany and West
Berlin and they also felt much
frustration in their dealings with the
West German leader Konrad Adenauer just
as Khrushchev was often very frustrated
with his German alloy Walter Ulbricht
both felt that their Germany was very
very important President Kennedy gave
voice to this when he met chairman
Khrushchev in the summit meeting in
Vienna in June of 1961 Khrushchev was
putting pressure on Kennedy essentially
saying you know why don't you give up
West Berlin are you
adding a war from there you know you
must be doing something bad because it
makes no logical sense for you to be
there why you there why don't you get
out and President Kennedy said if the US
was forced out of West Berlin us
commitments around the world would be
seen as mere scraps of paper worthless
the world would lose confidence in the
US and its commitments and the US would
not be seen as a serious country the US
would become isolated he said I did not
become president of the United States to
make us isolated in his eyes defending
West Berlin was the key to defending
Western Europe and he felt that if he
gave up West Berlin he would lose
Western Europe very quickly thereafter
and President Kennedy of course made
that very clear to his West German ally
in the similar way the Khrushchev often
said to the East German leader your
needs are our needs so I want to give
you a bit of a sense of the East German
leader Walter Ulbricht you've gotten
somewhat of a sense of Khrushchev
committed to communism very boisterous
very emotional Khrushchev just as you
saw him all excited and jovial there I
could have shown you another clip when
the you two went over the Soviet Union
they shot it down Francis Gary Powers
and there's an amazing clip of
Khrushchev yelling and screaming so
Khrushchev was you know passionate these
German leader Walter Ulbricht was not he
was the opposite very gray for all of
Khrushchev's color ohlbrecht was a
bureaucrat a hard-line Stalinist
definitely had no sense of humor and was
quite arrogant and really sort of felt
the Germans are a more sophisticated
people than the Russians and communism
was founded in Germany anyway and
besides he had once met Lenin which
Khrushchev had
Ulbricht love to mention that whenever
possible so when you read the documents
when you read the letters back and forth
when you read their interactions this is
not you know albric does not some you
know supply an ally instead he's he's
very persistent and self-assured and in
fact arrogant at times they made a very
interesting pair they were both at the
front lines in World War two and I think
the first time they met according to
crew Shaw's biography autobiography um
was at the front ulbricht as many of the
Communists from Germany and Europe spent
much of World War two in the Soviet
Union and he was on the Soviet side but
trying to go and get and sort of turn
German soldiers to join the Communist
side and Khrushchev met him one night
over dinner and some you know sort of
slapping him on the back and saying you
know so comrade ohlbrecht you know did
you recruit any spies today and you know
i mean you all know this is supposed to
be undercover anyway ohlbrecht would
have been mortified to be you know to
have it treated so lightly and to have
this discussed in such a way and of
course maybe he didn't turn any German
soldiers that day and he maybe didn't
want to talk about it but this is sort
of typical of Khrushchev sort of getting
right to it and you know you could just
see olbrich totally tensing up and
probably not knowing what to say to
Khrushchev Lobeck was also very
opportunistic he learned to take
advantage of what was obviously crew
shots great commitment to East Berlin in
East Germany as crew shas foreign policy
advisor electron offski has written
there were periods when Moscow was
literally bombarded by messages and
phone calls from East Berlin and this
clearly drove crew shot sort of nuts
which is why the title of my book is
driving the Soviets up the wall because
he just
wouldn't let up he just kept pushing and
pushing and pushing and let's close the
border and Khrushchev kept saying no one
of the most vivid examples of old bricks
bossy attitude with Khrushchev is a
letter he wrote to crew shafa January of
1961 about the economic problems in East
Germany about the refugee problem and
this is in the context of him continuing
to ask can't we close the border and
Khrushchev kept saying no why don't you
change your policy so people want to
stay in your country instead of leave
the country and will Brett kept saying
you know really it would be much easier
if we just closed the border so albric
took a different tact in this letter a
lengthy letter you know like 20 pages
long in which he explains to comrade
Khrushchev exactly why the situation is
so dire in East Germany and whose fault
it is and he says um you know in the
years after World War two while the West
was investing in west germany and
launched the Marshall Plan and was
giving West Germany all sorts of aid the
Soviets were practicing a ruthless
reparations policy taking everything you
could out of East Germany and that's why
we're in the situation we're in now
that's why our economies in dire straits
that's why everyone's leaving it's your
fault so you have to fix it by closing
the border uh you know if I was shocked
reading this letter I can only imagine
what brush-off thought um so you you get
the picture that you know as Peter
mentioned in the introduction um yes
there are obviously on the same side of
the Cold War they're both communist but
they also had some different interests
and Moscow of course had broad worldwide
interests which included of course
decent relations with the West so that
there wouldn't be a nuclear war all
bricks concern was much narrower it was
his country and East Berlin and even
more
airoli the refugee crisis you know that
was it he was obsessed with this crew
chef was concerned about that that's for
sure it was his most important now I he
knew it looked bad he wanted to do
something about it but he wanted to do
something about it as well as have lots
of other constructive relations with
other countries most especially the US
but also West Germany France Great
Britain and in the midst of all of this
began the split of the Soviets with the
Chinese which was a huge pole on
Khrushchev's attention which distracted
him at times from paying attention to
Obrecht so they had some different
interests and that is particularly clear
in this one interaction they had in june
of 1959 Khrushchev had begun a crisis in
Berlin the year before demanding that
essentially the wesley of West Berlin
and sign a treaty they're still had been
no treaty ending world war two with
Germany and he wanted the West to
recognize the East German state so
Khrushchev has been putting pressure on
the west he's launched his big public
campaign yet he's a completely different
person in private in June in Moscow he
has a summit meeting with ohlbrecht and
he suddenly says to all bricked the
opposite of what in fact is doing in
public he says we don't think it's worth
it now to push the West to the wall we
don't want to give the impression we are
seeking Western recognition of the East
German state the Americans don't want to
recognize East Germany they can't do
this for prestige reasons and besides we
would be offended they didn't recognize
us for 16 years and you want them to
recognize you after 10 you have to wait
at least 17 years
I mean if there was ever a document that
illustrates different interests of these
two powers this is it and you know you
could imagine the dour ohlbrecht being
appalled and very angry at this his is a
lie isn't quite measuring up here so uh
old brick begins to get frustrated or we
could say much more frustrated than he
has been for years of getting a refusal
to close the border so in the final year
before the wall is built he steps up the
pressure and these are again some of the
most fascinating smoking gun documents
found in both Moscow and East Berlin
about impending East German unilateral
moves to close the border and Berlin in
spite of the Soviets telling them no so
there are two documents here in the one
at the top it's October of 1960 and the
second secretary at the Soviet embassy
in East Berlin kazanov cables back to
Moscow and he says our friends are
studying the possibility of stopping the
exodus of the population of East Germany
through West Berlin one of such measures
by our friends could be the cessation of
free movement through the sectoral
border he goes on to say given that this
would have consequences for our work in
West Berlin it would be expedient to
discuss with our German friends at the
appropriate level the question of the
regime on the sectoral border in Berlin
so he's saying look all of a sudden on
their own the East Germany these seams
the East Germans want to close off this
border well if they do that obviously
the West is going to retaliate and it's
going to be a lot harder for Soviet
diplomats to go into West Berlin and do
all sorts of things diplomacy and
espionage of course so Khrushchev rights
to ohlbrecht and says I know you're
upset it's a difficult situation but
don't do anything he writes after the
elections when President Kennedy has
been elected in November of 1960s look
there's a new American president I am
going to want to talk to him about
Berlin and in fact I have told him I
won't do anything in Berlin to change
anything until I talk to him so I've
given president you know president-elect
Kennedy my word so don't do anything and
I'll meet with you in Moscow so November
30th 1960 ohlbrecht and Khrushchev meet
in Moscow and Khrushchev says I
understand it's terrible what's going on
the refugees the the Espionage all the
economic difficulties i agree with you
and we're going to ultimately have to do
something but not now don't do anything
I want a way to talk to President
Kennedy after which ulbrich writes that
wonderful hottie letter I told you about
a month and a half after that and he
keeps being told don't do anything
finally in the spring Khrushchev and
Kennedy set a date for their summit
meeting they're going to meet in Vienna
at the beginning of June and Khrushchev
says 20 break point blank don't do
anything before I meet with President
Kennedy so then you have the second
document which is two weeks before he's
going to meet with President Kennedy the
Soviet ambassador in East Berlin cables
back in a panic to foreign minister
Gromyko in Moscow and he says our
friends would like to establish now such
control on the sectoral border between
democratic and West Berlin which would
allow them to as they say close the door
to the west and reduce the exodus of the
population from East Germany he goes on
in the second bottom paragraph to say
our German friends sometimes exercise in
patience and a somewhat one-sided
approach to the problem not always
studying the interests of the entire
socialist camp or the international
situation at the given moment evidence
of this for example is their efforts to
stop free movement between East
East Germany and West Berlin as soon as
possible by any means so you can imagine
Khrushchev was not happy to get this two
weeks before he's supposed to meet with
Kennedy and it looks like Ulbricht isn't
going along with the plan of not doing
anything again ohlbrecht is told don't
do anything i'm about to meet with
Kennedy so Khrushchev and Kennedy meet
in Vienna and the item on the agenda is
West Berlin and I already read you what
President Kennedy said you know we are
not leaving and Khrushchev was even sort
of more aggressive than Kennedy was
saying we are staying in east berlin
west berlin is rightfully really a part
of East Germany and he basically
threatened President Kennedy with war
over this and he said we are going to
sign a treaty with the East German
government that will turn over to them
control of the all-important Western
access routes across the 110 miles of
East German territory the routes that
got you from West Germany to West Berlin
President Kennedy took him aside after
lunch with only the translators there he
said look I want to be perfectly clear
are you telling me you are going to turn
over control of those access routes our
way of getting into West Berlin are you
saying you're going to turn those over
T's Germany because if you are it means
war and Khrushchev said that is what I'm
saying so it was a terrible meeting in
Vienna and after Khruschev left there he
finally gave ulbricht the go-ahead he
had been hoping he would come up with
some some sort of agreement although
what you know rationally it was hardly
likely that President Kennedy and
chairman Khrushchev were going to come
up with some compromise on Berlin given
that they had such different views and
at long last Khrushchev gave in to
obridge another one
foreign minister Andrei Gromyko yes I'm
totally yes okay okay yes um so um this
is from the Stasi archives the East
German secret police archives you see in
the middle of the page Rosa rose the
code name for closing the border in
Berlin the code name for essentially
building the Berlin Wall was rose now um
once the border was closed on the night
between august twelfth and August
thirteenth it was a Saturday night a
warm you know August weekend most people
were out at their country houses out in
the forests and lakes of Berlin they
weren't in town happened in the middle
of the night you know it was fairly easy
people weren't going to stop them and
caught everyone by surprise including
the people at the CIA in West Berlin
with whom I have spoken at length about
this on everyone was caught off guard
including the East German people um
initially Khrushchev said go gradually
and see how the West responds so they
started with barbed wire and lo and
behold how did the West respond barely
at all except for West Berlin mayor
Billy brunt who was absolutely outraged
and sort of yelled and screamed as much
as he possibly could but President
Kennedy was on V you know on vacation at
Hyannis poured out on his boat talked to
his advisors he said in confidence to
his advisers a wall as a hell of a lot
better than a war he had been very
worried that this refugee Exodus was
going to somehow escalate military was
going to get involved the West German
military was going to try to somehow
open the border and then NATO would have
to get involved President Kennedy been
very worried so he essentially felt this
is a defensive measure they've put up
this barbed wire all on East German
territory they haven't touched West
Berlin
yes its surrounding West Berlin but it
isn't touching the soil of West Berlin
so the West sent protest notes but that
was it the East Germans in Soviets
absolutely congratulated each other they
said the adversary took fewer
countermeasures than anticipated you
know they said they had no idea this you
know we caught them completely by
surprise and then in fact the US reached
out to resume talks about Germany with
the Soviets so the the Communists were
very relieved now once it was clear the
West wasn't going to stop it the
question was do we just leave the barbed
wire or do we in fact build a wall now
believe it or not the East German
military leaders favored the barbed wire
they said a barbed where it's totally
transparent you can see easily if
someone is coming up to it and trying to
escape a wall cast shadows someone we
could come right up could be in the
shadow of the wall we wouldn't know they
could somehow get over quickly we prefer
the barbed wire in olbrich said no way
it invites people to escape it invites
people to break through I want a rock
solid cement wall and that's what he got
but the Soviets were still worried even
afterwards about controlling their East
German ally and a month after the border
was closed in late-september Khrushchev
wrote to Obrecht and he said we are
beginning talks with the u.s. with
Secretary of State Rusk in New York
about Germany therefore such steps which
could exacerbate the situation
especially in Berlin should be avoided
in this connection it is especially
appropriate to abstain from new measures
which could change the control order set
up by the East German government on the
border with West Berlin so Khrushchev
was still worried
therefore he decided he would stop with
just closing the border around West
Berlin he decided not to carry out his
threat of turning over control of the
access routes between West Germany and
West Berlin to the East German leader
the East German leader of course wanted
control over those we could shut down
all the flights carrying the refugees
out and all the cars carrying the
refugees out Khrushchev decided he
wanted to be the one to control the
level of tension between the Soviets and
the west and he didn't want olbrich to
so in essence ulbricht achieved the
height of his influence with Moscow in
getting them to close the border in
Berlin but also sort of lost any
influence thereafter by how he did it
because he had been so persistent so hot
a so unilateral at times that the
Soviets felt he was too risky and
wouldn't give him anything else thank
you very much
I think the most appropriate closing
words you could have used was I rest my
case I was a brilliant presentation it
reminded me i was as I was listening of
the of the guns of august where we had a
chance many many years later to look
back at all the misunderstandings and
gaps that led to of course world war one
in this case it's extraordinary to see
this glimpse into the thinking that went
into the erection of the wall what I
would like to do is go ahead and do QA
we have microphones on either side so
I'll try and get a balance between these
why don't we start with you are two
things one you arrived at just the right
time so did you get a piece of the wall
and secondly now that we're going
through another wall building episode in
the Middle East you have any insight
from Berlin's experience to Israel's
attempt thank you very much yes of
course I got several pieces the wall
when I was there but interestingly i
also got more pieces this past spring i
spent the spring as a fellow at the
american academy in berlin working on my
second book which looks at how the
Germans have been coming to terms with
East Germany's past what they've done
with the leaders with the Stasi files
this kind of thing and what they've done
with the remains of the wall which is
tear down most of it of course but
there's some pieces some pieces that are
left and in fact there you know it's
actually easier than you might think to
to stroll around what used to be no
man's land and pick up some big pieces
of the wall so I got another big piece
recently I have actually thought a fair
amount about this Israeli wall or fence
and you know any similarities or
differences with of course the Berlin
Wall I mean mostly their differences so
many differences you know the East
Berlin Wall was built to keep people in
the Israeli wall is to keep you know
people out suicide bombers particularly
out but there's one thing I think they
have very much in common which is that
they're both at the front line of the
international conflict of the period and
they also both have behind them a
reluctant superpower you know as I've
made clear the Soviets were very
reluctant to allow these Germans to
close the border in Berlin and the US
has also been reluctant I mean we've
gone along but you know we know full
well just as the Soviets knew full well
we look bad and crew chef wrote in his
memoirs you know I knew that by building
this wall people would say what kind of
us workers and peasants paradises this
if you have to wall people in and
certainly at the beginning of the
building of this fence President Bush
and Secretary of State pal were you know
making a lot of public statements
initially saying you know this isn't a
good idea of course they've given in and
I think it's it's a similar dynamic in
that they both feel both the Soviets
with these Germans in the US with Israel
feel you know this is our crucial Ally
at the frontline of a global conflict
and we don't like what they're doing but
we feel that our relationship with them
is so important that we can't or we
don't really want to stop them there is
a book signing afterwards that a number
of the stories that you told were so
juicy that is so filled with flavor they
just run all through the book these
confrontations with Khrushchev and and
others and how he's expelled with power
and that's that's a very vital part of
your book it was hand yes sir since the
building of the wall was supper such a
precipitous act that may well have
resulted in World War three what gave
the Soviets confidence in your research
did you come across anything that gave
the them pre wall confidence that the
West would really not do anything that
I've often wondered you know if there
was a smoking gun Paris the phrase you
know out of Vienna that that was part of
the the back room conversation that well
okay you do that now
do anything mhm mm-hmm yep that's a
great question and well Khrushchev
wasn't completely confident he was
always worried and again this is one of
the fascinating things the difference
between Khrushchev and public who was
often ranting and threatening and in
private where he was very restrained and
cautious compared to ulbricht Khrushchev
was always restrained and cautious in
patients and really afraid of nuclear
war again even though there he's the one
who put the missiles in Cuba and by on
that let me just say that I think he
learned to tactical lessons from the
Berlin Wall that he applied in Cuba but
they failed in Cuba and the two tactical
lessons were we can prepare something in
secret and the West won't stop us once
they find out they prepared the closing
of the border in secret and the West
didn't stop them okay trying to put the
missiles like Cuba they didn't quite
pull that off the West found them before
the missiles will fully operational and
the u.s. insisted they get them out but
I think he learned those two lessons
from Berlin they just didn't work the
next time so it looks like he was very
risky but in private you know your
question how how confident was he that
there would not be a war as a result of
him closing the wall closing the border
and building the wall he was always
worried I'm the way to meet President
Kennedy in Vienna both Kennedy and
Khrushchev were really worried and I'm
the way they both stopped and met with
allies Kennedy stopped and met with de
Gaulle and France and said you know what
am I going to do how can i make
Khrushchev understand that I'm serious
and to go all kind of said you know good
luck I don't know and krish I've stopped
in Czechoslovakian met with Novotny um
and kept talking about his fear of war
and his uncertainty of this new young
President Kennedy he said um said i'm
ninety-five percent certain the West
will not go to war but five percent I
don't know and he said we don't know
Kennedy yet the events in key
lubish oh he isn't very clever meaning
the Bay of Pigs fiasco but the Bay of
Pigs also showed two crucial off the
Kennedy was willing to sort of resort to
force so even though Kennedy failed it
really worried him because he thought
you know this guy he's young and kind of
aggressive and if he did it there maybe
he's going to resort to force in Berlin
also so he and he crew chef in his
typical way when he met with the other
leaders of the Communist block in early
August to sort of get a rubber stamp
decision to close the border in Berlin
he kept saying um you know the West
isn't very scary it's going to be fun
but you never know and we must be
prepared for all eventualities but I'm
sure it'll be fun but on the other hand
and this is what crucial speech was like
so he was definitely worried and and as
I read from that one document that said
the adversary took fewer Kennard
countermeasures than anticipated you
know he was very relieved so he was very
worried um he figured you know 95% he
said they won't go to war but you know
if the five percent if they do we we
have to be prepared now you asked was
there a signal many many people have
have wondered this wasn't there some you
know secret agreement in which Kennedy
basically said we know you've got a
crisis with refugees we understand the
problem you know as long as you deal
with that in a defensive way and don't
touch West Berlin you know we'll let it
go that that did not occur but Kennedy
sure made it clear over and over
especially at Vienna but also in his
speech on july twenty fifth and in
letters he made it very clear don't
touch our access to West Berlin and
don't touch West Berlin he always talked
about West Berlin so if you're looking
closely you're noticing he's not talking
about East Berlin and he's not talking
about moving back and forth between East
and West Berlin and Khrushchev was
watching closely so he certainly you
know would have felt Kennedy's concern
is West Berlin and the access routes to
it and that's why he did not give in
when Khrushchev said give me control
over those access routes there was no
way he was going to do that yes right
here awesome presentation if you would
have been my professor I've may have
learned a little more thank you um would
you please share a little more about how
you came to get access to the documents
and being a woman did that have anything
to do with it like these Romeo spies or
something um well um access to the
documents i generally in these kinds of
cases you have to write you know you
write a formal letter on stationery from
your university this is who I am this is
my background as many stamped letters
that attest who you are really help and
this is what I always tell my students
you know the president of the university
the chair of your department the more
sort of official because you know Europe
in some ways is more hierarchical a sort
of status conscious than the u.s. I mean
here you right to the National Archives
here's what I'm doing you know I wanted
to work on this subject and I'll be
there on this date but there you need
more to back you up in these former
communist regimes it also helped that
the Cold War international history
project based here in Washington had an
agreement with the key Central Committee
archive they will party archived in
Moscow for a conference and those of us
who were going to be presenting papers
at this conference got access so there I
was with you know a small group and I
didn't have to do anything on my own
which was very helpful and in that case
the Cold War project was you know giving
them some money and buying them
much-needed Xerox machines and you know
microfilm readers in this kind of thing
being a woman is sort of a problem and
this is what I again I tell my women
stew
since there's you have more of a need to
prove yourself in these kinds of places
more they need to come in with these
stamped letters and you know appear very
serious and being young you know I was
definitely younger at the time 12 years
ago and you know people they didn't take
you quite as seriously so it was always
the case for the first several weeks
especially in Moscow where I was
essentially proving myself and there
were bringing me mostly boring stupid
documents my favorite case they brought
me a stack of documents what was it New
York Times translated into Russian you
know this had been top secret then I
heard thank you very much but you know I
could get that in the West and I did not
come to Moscow for that course can't say
it that way but that's what I was
thinking so at the beginning it was real
pressure on me to prove myself and
coming from the west so being young
being a woman coming from the West
they're all thinking and again you with
the spy museum will appreciate this
they're all thinking you're either
working for the CIA or for you know big
tabloid so you're looking for things in
the archives so they're gonna make them
look bad and then you're going to splash
it across the headlines that's what they
were thinking at first and particularly
the Central Committee archives where
they had not had many foreigners the
foreign ministry archives there had been
more foreigners there but in the Central
Committee the top party archive you know
I was a new occurrence and you know
they're sort of watching me and it was
only on my last day that they finally
got up the guts to ask me so all sorts
of questions most importantly how is it
that someone sort of so young could come
here like where did you get the money at
which point I said you know my
university and they looked at me because
Russian universities don't have
fellowships they don't have the money to
send their students going off on
research trips around the world so again
they you know you sense that they sort
of didn't believe me because they don't
know that they haven't seen that they
don't have private foundations giving
fellowships to graduate students so I
explained all of this and so you start
to feel you know your sort of a cultural
ambassador and you're trying to explain
what the education system is like in the
United States
and how different it is the other crazy
experience I had also when that archive
was with my laptop computer which was
again sort of new for them and the
archivist I was working with you know
she would come out and bring me some
documents and put the documents down
next to my laptop and I'd be typing when
I both Cyrillic in English and she's
looking at my screen and she's seeing
the Cyrillic and she's seeing the
documents here and she finally said you
know how does this work and it's clear
she thinks it works by osmosis that
somehow these documents being near the
computer sort of sucking in these
documents so you know I mean terra
incognita which was one of the wonderful
things about being one of the first
people there but it also meant you I had
it was longer because they had to
develop trust in me and get to
understand that I was a serious scholar
it was a fascinating experience though
I'll tell you that okay in conducting
your research what was the most
surprising our most unexpected piece of
information that you came across um the
biggest surprise was what I've talked
about at some length here the arrogance
of the East German leader um the the
degree of it just really surprised me
and that the Soviet leader kept putting
up with this many people ask me why
didn't they just get rid of this guy
will break TV was driving them so nuts
and he wasn't moderating his policies
the way they kept asking to why didn't
they just get rid of him and it's
basically because of who crew chef was
that he felt he would look bad and that
you know the whole world was watching
and it would be sort of an admission of
defeat so the biggest surprise really
was the nature of that relationship and
that Ulbricht had the confidence
sometimes the arrogance and really the
persistence to not give up
um so that general dynamic and then some
of the specific documents I talked about
but particularly that letter when he
says you know why is this the case you
know it's your fault that's because of
post-world war two soviet reparations
policy i mean that's incredible to me
that he was writing that to the soviet
leader and getting away with it the
questions one right here
what happened to the eastern leadership
who was put on trial after the Wall fell
were they convicted or varying things
the the man Erich Honecker who had been
the leader from 71 to 89 and who had in
fact had been in charge of closing the
border for valter ulbrich because he was
the number two for all bricked he was
suddenly old and sick even though he'd
been ruling the country until recently
and actually I think he got liver cancer
and so he was on trial for a very short
time and then they let him go for health
reasons at one point he fled to Moscow
than the Soviet sent him back and you
know put him on trial and finally for
health reasons they let him go in fact
they let him go join his daughter in
Chile where he lived for another couple
of years that makes a lot of people very
upset that sort of the top guy
essentially was led off the other top
guy Eric milka who had been head of the
secret police the Stasi similar thing he
again old and increasingly feeble and
had some health problems and they
couldn't one of the problems of the
Western legal system you know the demand
for very specific evidence and even
though he'd been head of the secret
police that was as they said the sword
and the shield of the party and really
kept the communist party in power and
enforce the border regime and all of
that the best thing they could get him
on was evidenced that he had taken part
in the murder of two German police in
1931 again people are very unhappy with
that so he was ultimately led off for
health reasons um the the more recent
top Politburo guys egon krenz who said
don't blame us blame the Soviets was
sentenced to something like seven and a
half years in jail of which he served
four others got two or three years in
jail border guard trials were very
interesting because
of course it's the leaders the political
leaders who made the decision you must
shoot people trying to escape but it's
the border guards who pulled the trigger
so they also went on trial this was very
complicated because of course they could
say I was following orders which is
quite problematic in Germany after the
Nazi period you know using that defense
isn't isn't great but of course there is
a certain justification to it most of
the border guards got sentences but then
were let off on probation um so for many
people there's there's a sense that the
trials have been more about exposing
sort of the evils of the East German
regime and getting it out there for
history to know and then mostly letting
the people go it's also been very
complicated because it's not the East
Germans who've been carrying out the
trials because these German regime
collapsed it's been the United Germany
but who were the main judges and lawyers
are of course West Germans because it's
the West room and legal system that took
over so there have been tinges of what
some East Germans have called Victor's
justice you know it's not fair it was
legal then we were supposed to shoot
people you know was on the books you
know that we were allowed to and now
you're trying us by other standards and
you know you've taken over our country
and um it's a very complicated yet
interesting situation which is in fact
why it's a big part of my next book um
so that's that's an answer okay one last
question over here yeah it's me oh this
may be the subject of your next book but
or the first chapter at least but as we
all know in Washington spin controls a
big thing did you see anything in your
research that you know was the either
the East German or the Soviet spin
control as far as public perception
things like that that you know you found
interesting um yeah um
during this crisis over Berlin there
were many times when sort of the main
way the Communists were talking about it
was we need German unification and the
West is refusing this it's all the West
fought that Germany is divided we need
German unification and and we also need
finally a peace treaty to end world war
two and at one point olbrich the leader
of East Germany said you know what
really plays far better than talking
about these things is talking about the
threat of West German nuclear weapons
because in the late 50s NATO was
starting to deploy some nuclear weapons
of West Germany and there was a big
question how much control where the West
Germans going to have over these and
needless say after World War two the
Soviets were very afraid of any German
militarism and certainly westrom and
militarism and but it was clear that the
East German leader was saying look for
propaganda in Germany the way we really
can get people on our side is by
emphasizing this threat from West
Germany getting nuclear weapons that's
are the most clear case I think of where
they talked purely for you know
propaganda for the public ok well thank
you for a very spirited animated
presentation made for regulation